Benjamin Franklin said those who would
give up Essential Liberty to purchase a
little temporary safety deserve neither
liberty nor safety so consider this the
police are going to start systematically
using live facial recognition software
which independent analysis says is 81%
inaccurate anyway under a government
which I believe is hugely hostile
towards human rights be a foreign
secretary who doesn't believe in
economic and social rights or a Home
Secretary who once reportedly advocated
the death penalty not to mention the
fact that the snoopers charter
legislation had to be withdrawn then
reintroduce then amended again because
it violated EU privacy laws now
obviously our safety and security is
vital and facial recognition software to
fight crime and improve our national
security could be really helpful with
that but only if it was used lawfully it
would need to be coupled with a binding
written constitution which permanently
guaranteed minimum standards on right to
privacy a right to be forgotten due
process non-discrimination free speech
and even a right to life and right now
we just don't have that so I'm really
glad that you raised this debate Femi
and thank you for for raising it
something I'm very concerned about so
some of you may know I've taken on a few
legal cases in my life and won all of
them without exception there's one case
I took on because a particular company
named Thomson Reuters well cheque had
erroneously listed me under a category
red terrorism designation they've since
issued a statement in court apologized
retracted it and paid a settlement which
is why I'm allowed to mention it now the
point I make here is if somebody's
listed like extinction rebellion were
recently in error by the police and
really under a terrorism designation and
then you roll out facial recognition
those photographs that the cameras
capture will cross-reference them with
suspects in this case terrorism suspects
but of course there's two examples where
it's been done in gross error and
imagine the the the in justices that can
occur when you're doing that to every
single person in the country and then I
only need to mention one more word and
that is China for what the potential
consequence is because it lets you hear
talk about facial recognition cameras
just look at how they work magic police
say the technology works like this the
faces of anyone not on a watch list
appear pixelated this is what happens
when a suspect above is caught in the
crowd below the potential match alerts
officers on the ground and they decide
whether to approach the suspect you know
my worry is we are already the most
spied upon country in the free world and
my concern is that as you just touched
on there is that if cameras these
cameras are installed it will bring
surveillance levels in this country to
the levels of that of Communist China we
already have half a million of these
cameras in London alone and the other
part of my argument is you know Boris's
city's gonna put 20,000 more coppers on
the street you know there is much
evidence to show that if you have if you
have more coppers on the street
the crime rate Falls I don't want the
twenty thousand coppers holed up in a
room somewhere monitoring cameras all
day long looking for for people who
might be shoplifting in Tesco's and it
would be that I mean I mean I'm trying
to think the bad stories have already
emerged there was there wasn't for
testing these in London there was a guy
who didn't want he saw what they were
doing and he pulled his jumper on his
cab down to hide his identity he was
immediately raked over by the police and
charged with what was the cut was
disorderly behavior you got fined 90
quid for that and they're not even
operating it and that's that's a way
from a you know it gives to me it gives
governments unprecedented power to track
our daily lives and that doesn't marry
with it with a democracy and that point
is backed up by the by that by the by
the polls because 46% of Brits think
that they should have to consent to or
be able to opt out of anything like yeah
we didn't vote for it we didn't know
anything about it they've just said
they're gonna die it's a great idea I
know Nick engravers assistant
commissioner at the Metropolitan Police
we are using a tried and tested
technology and have taken a considered
and transparent approach in order to
arrive at this point we all want to live
and work in a city which is safe the
public rightly expect us to use widely
available technology to stop criminals
equally I have to be sure that we have
the right safeguards and transparency in
place to ensure that we protect people's
privacy and human rights I believe our
careful
and considered deployment of live facial
recognition strikes that balance I'm not
here to defend something your apps that
you're right to point out the shocking
shocking level 81% it has to be
perfected I'm not here to defend
something obviously cause you issues and
is blatantly wrong I'm here to defend
the principle which is if you've got
people attending a rock concert a rugby
game a football game whatever it might
be and do we need to talk about the area
in a grand a concept if that could
prevent that taking on board what you
say it has to work in can't be 80
percent wrong then I am ready to sign
off on it I was going to mention that as
well I mean when you were reading out
your intro I was thinking if I was a
parent of one of the children who lost
their lives in Manchester would you have
welcomed the use of that sort of
surveillance technology of course you
would it would have saved too you know
tens of life so my question is are you
complaining this is unethical or
inaccurate if they made the technology
completely stop in if they made the
technology completely foolproof would
you be in favor of it it's a matter of
trust we don't have a written
constitution which means we don't know
what the government is going to do with
the information that they get from this
facial recognition technology what we
are dealing what we're dealing with
whether go to government that they've
already put Greenpeace on a terrorist
watchlist they deported a hundred new
citizens by mistake in 2000 no they said
sorry
it sent a hundred letters of deportation
to EU citizens by mistake in 2006 2016
we've got the wind rush whether we
deported our own citizens like we're
dealing with the government that cannot
be trusted that say can we find our
there's a organization that monitors
this sort of abuse of civil liberties
and let's hear from them and this is
from silky Carla who's the director of
Big Brother Watch mm-hmm never before
have members of the public been treated
like walking ID cards subjected to an
ongoing police lineup that our
identities have to be biometrically
checked to make sure we're not criminals
that's a complete inversion of the of
the traditional presumption of innocence
that is so at the heart of British civil
liberties and that's why I think this is
none
an assault on well but Remy was talking
about the issue of trust here and if I
trusted governments to use this progress
they absolutely do in America San
Francisco has bounded many other states
are about to follow suit because of the
inaccuracies ik what you don't want is
governments and companies being
secretive about where and how they're
using them and I fear that will happen
I fear that well so the argument you're
using about security I just wonder where
why that argument is all of course
always applied so that it's always the
thin end of the wedge we always try and
erode civil liberties by arguing that it
makes us safer and I'm just wondering
where you draw the line on that kind of
conversation we traditionally in this
country do that action I'm so tradition
of not having to show your papers and
all that why I think I mean my question
was that when people try and make a case
for eroding civil liberties it is
usually a security argument they use and
of course that can be applied on
multiple things do not buy my argument
about a pop concert I do think you're
like us so visit their things there's a
it's my question to you the trade-off is
that of course I can make I could make
this country a lot safer by forcing
compulsory ID cards everyone has to give
their fingerprint and DNA facial
recognition at what point do we say it's
too much power for the state to have to
keep a sex did anybody see a drama
recently called the capture and it
featured exactly this about these facial
recognition cameras it showed you the
government misusing and abusing it to
fit up certain people for certain
offenses and I fear that's what that's
what kind of anyone who's watch person
of interest knows that this can be
misused I know you've probably might not
have watched that show but the point is
I don't have a problem with the
technology in and of itself it is a
simple matter of trust we don't know if
the government if the government put in
a legally binding Constitution whereby
you had minimums down Senna's guaranteed
on right to privacy right to life and
those sorts of things then that wouldn't
then that would be make me a lot more
comfortable with it but right now the
government in place not a massive fan
they have absolute powers there's no
input from any other parties
would just be the connection it'll beat
you'll be just it'll be a government
that is massive well the new iPhone 11
has got facial recognition technology
presumably that's all uploading to a
cloud and who knows who got access to
that data make it right